let's jump into audience questions for
the week first ones from Cynthia Cynthia
says hey David Trump recently mentioned
that maybe we should bring back earmarks
you mentioned that this makes quid pro
quo even easier but can you talk a
little bit about the pros and cons of
earmarking I mean listen the pros I'm
not going to say there aren't pros to
earmarking that it is a way to be able
to fund specific projects and sometimes
that's important for politics right so
we can imagine situations where a
general appropriation of money for
infrastructure in a particular County it
might go to particular projects that
we've identified as important or it
might not
so you're marking money for specific
projects there's no doubt that if you
want a particular project to take place
an earmark is a good way to do it the
problem is that in practice earmarking
started being used in completely
unrelated bills so you would have a bill
about infrastructure and there would be
provisions about some kickback to a
financial services firm who had donated
a bunch of money to some elected
official it opens the door to absolutely
even more rampant quid pro quo cronyism
and corruption so the question would be
would there be a way to expose ourselves
to the positives of earmarking to the
extent that they hypothetically exist
without allowing for all of the
corruption that earmarks bring in and I
don't know that there really is a way to
do that how would you set something up
like that I I think the better ways to
just have stricter campaign finance
reform because then you don't have to
make some backroom deal with a
politician to get what you want past
right well oh why so he's working in the
interest of the American public rather
than you know specific donors yeah so
let's explore that if we are to assume
that an earmark would be the repayment
of a campaign donation that maybe came
earlier from a company then it's true
that if we restructured campaign finance
and eliminated even the circumstances
that would lead to those quid pro quos
we might be able to get away with doing
earmark
in a way that did not allow the
corruption and cronyism to run rampant
but basically what we're getting back to
is and I've been saying this for a while
no matter what issue is important to you
you kind of have to deal with campaign
finance in order to get at the heart of
what is impeding us from really making
progress on that issue and that's kind
of what we're saying like yeah we can
pick out some positives of earmarking in
an ideal world but that ideal world is
one where campaign finance is completely
different than it is and I just think we
have to have clean bills on this sort of
thing as a general thing if your
Congressman or your senator and you are
in Montana yeah you may not have a
reason to vote for the bridge in South
Carolina sure but if you have like a
groundswell of support for an
infrastructure bill yeah I think that's
the thing that you have to move forward
on instead not just your specific
project or another and I don't think
it's crazy to say that there are
specific projects we want funded the
problem is that usually those decisions
are not made by calculating what would
give us the biggest social benefit it's
calculated by what companies do we want
to give a contract to because they've
supported us and that's sort of
inherently the problem yeah it's funny
how Trump floated the idea of bringing
back earmark yeah and right away the
house decided to I don't know if they
had a vote on it but at least consider
it
yep because if they can get back into
that crony capitalism and politics that
they've been doing you know five ten
years ago and they've an easy way to do
it and the president's behind it I
wouldn't oh my goodness of course the
first thing they would do is try to take
advantage of that